[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as I like to call it dear Alex and
it's a comedy podcast for two brothers
and sometimes a special guest like today
Alex Goldman of reply-all answer your
questions give you dubious advicing
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon how are you Alex
I am great I'm great thank you for
asking yeah good so Alex you do a
podcast it's on it's on the podcast
places all of them it makes it very
popular and and and very good and
interesting it's called reply all and I
really appreciate you hanging out with
me here under your hangar John I assume
now that I will have to be a guest on
reply I will at where I will talk about
my obsession with I don't know
like well like early internet and
mutations all your base are belong to us
that stuff I don't know what yes yes
what did you ask what an immune is yes
how could I know something about the
internet that you don't know what is it
like so like you remember these they're
like these flash animations that were
done back in the day like very low
sodium and Neil says Auriga and yes yeah
like they did one for a yachtie you know
these things you know I don't know so I
just you know I I loved that and I love
that I love that those things have had
an impact on the modern internet that no
one understands so like the the sort of
like like wave of influence is so far
past being influenced by that one of the
things like they still there it's still
hidden inside of the subculture of the
Internet one of the things that's nice
about the internet that doesn't feel the
same way in the larger culture is that
the Internet is still relatively young
enough that you know you can sort of see
the butterfly wings fluttering and watch
the you know the massive change that
came from that thing like you can trace
a lot of things back to their origins in
a very interesting way oh that's totally
true yeah and and and makes your
Podcast very interesting so I love I
love to watch and see it if you ever I
would definitely want Nilsa serega to be
part of a story on reply-all someday
because he can't like he's just had so
many different things that are like
people know about them but they don't
know that he's the person that made them
he is like an Internet polymath he has
done he has had many lives on the
internet all of them sort of uniquely
weird he does something I'm just like
this is so creative yeah like how do you
not run out of these right well I mean
you just yeah you just got to keep make
just keep making things I'll tell you
about my favorite Nilsa serega project
after the podcast because it's a little
bit blue so I feel like I can't bring it
up right now but we usually do we answer
questions from our listeners so we're
gonna do that unless you have a short
poem for us I do have a short poem for
you oh my gosh okay I wanted to throw
some shine to a friend of mine her
name's Marissa Crawford she's a poet in
New York City and I have known her since
college and her poems are frequently
about the sort of weird feelings that
people have as teenagers about love and
life and friends and so I grabbed one
from one of her books and I'm going to
read it to you now okay it is untitled
it goes like this
Carrie used to draw the anarchy symbol
everywhere but Janey said if there was
an ER key that would mean that killers
like Charles Manson would be running
free to attack and murder our mothers
there was this thing that happened when
Carrie moved away at first we talked a
lot and wrote letters but then missing
each other got too hard and we became
comfortably numb we used our lunch money
to buy a bag of purple skittles and a
bag of Chex Mix from the vending machine
and then save the rest for if Pink Floyd
ever got back together
the end
oh yeah that's my kind of poem Alex it's
just yeah that didn't turn my brain off
I had this problem where poetry turns my
brain off because it's not structured
like normal speech but that worked yeah
I have a hard time with poetry too it's
nice that the one friend I have who
decided to actually become a poet writes
poetry that actually connects with the
way that I experience the world
yeah just like narrative Lee not like it
just like functionally not any kind of
yeah not in terms of like the the
metaphor the subject matter but like I
just can't do it it's so weird I yeah
just talk like a normal person poets
I apologize poets talk that way ever
whichever way you want to and I will
endeavor to change my brain and not make
you change yours no judgments you're
doing fine I did I did remember a moment
when I was drawing an anarchy symbol in
high school and somebody was like what
kind of anarchy do you believe in and I
was like oh man that is way above my pay
grade that feels don't even that
question yeah I'm not like I'm not I'm
not like I haven't read books by these
people I'm just drawing the anarchy
symbol I believe in the name anarchy
that lets me draw this cool symbol with
impunity yeah I believe in the kind of
Anarchy where I don't have to like go to
school all the time you know what real
Anarchy is not learning the ins and outs
of what anarchy actually is a plus all
right all right we've got some questions
from our listener I'm gonna start with
this one from Cameron who asks dear Hank
and Alex as a senior in high school I've
been applying to many scholarships and
universities and one consistent thread
in application essays is how have you
significantly grown and changed over the
last four years in a time in my life
that is incredibly stressful and
everybody's changing what do you think
counts as significant change is this
change dependent on personality or
offense what would each of you consider
significant changes you have undergone
in the last four years
not an African country just a person
Cameron
so not Cameroon okay do you ever see so
I do want to admit that like as a 37
year old person I have not changed as
much as I did between the ages of like
14 and 18 but I have changed I do have I
have changed significantly and mostly
that has to do with my professional life
and also I got a baby so I also have to
be different from yours significant
changes yeah that's what I was going to
say yeah I had a kid but but from 14 to
18 everything changes
right yes yeah be like I have a bunch of
new feelings for people and things and I
mean I think like that what they're
looking for is that like you are
interacting with the world in a rich way
and so like like I think that you cannot
go wrong on a college admissions essay
by saying I used to think that things
were simple and now I see that they are
complex not only that but like between
when I was 14 I was just trying to
survive I didn't have an idea about how
the world worked or or and I didn't care
to have one but by the time I was 19 I
developed like a value system not a
coherent one necessarily anarchy the mic
value system was about how cool it was
until the NRG simple but I do think that
you know at you learn you come to
understand what it means to be valuable
to someone or to value someone over that
period of time and that's like a huge
change yeah it's pretty remarkable like
that that shift and that this happened
especially late for me of like accepting
that my parents were people and I need
to treat them like humans right like
something as simple as that but also
like you find that in your peers you
find that like you find that other
people valuing you and you find the joy
in that and like that in the terror
of of wondering whether or not that's a
real thing or an imagined thing or or
not seeing it happen when it is
happening because we are so good at
ignoring people actually caring about us
yeah like I think I think that like no
funny answers here I think that this is
legit like it's a great thing to always
be thinking about is like how am i
different now than I was last year how
am i growing and like and how am i how
am i doing a better job of imagining the
world and myself and other people I have
never had that thought and now I'm
wondering how little I've grown over the
past thirty plus years I apologize
dear Alex and Hank I recently brought a
college friend home for Thanksgiving
because he didn't have anywhere else to
go during these three days with my
family he was very rude toward some of
my family members and they all kind of
hate him now okay I used to like
spending time with him but now all I can
think about is how rude he was to my
family I want to bring it up but I don't
know how and I hate confrontation I kind
of just want to stop communication with
him altogether because I don't even know
if I want to be friends with him anymore
I'm confused what should I do
not the American Idol judge Paula wait a
second Paula do you think that Paula
Abdul is just an American Idol judge and
that's what she's famous for yeah she's
definitely famous for straight up or I
guess you know what she's actually
famous for that one with the animated
cat opposites attract
yeah opposites attract yeah either like
that's a fascinating world that I live
in now where I realized that some people
think that Paula Abdul is just an
American Idol judge that's that's the
thing because I've never seen that show
and I did not even know that Paula Abdul
was an American Idol judge I just
assumed that that's who you mean I
didn't either until I assumed that you
knew and that's what you say googling
Paula American Idol it must be yeah
Paula Abdul singer-songwriter Paula
Abdul married to Brad Beckerman from
1996 to 1998 and Emilio Estevez for
1992 to 1994 you didn't know that no wow
she married the repo man
well apparently apparently straight-up
is actually her biggest hit so you were
right the first time
that's according to Google anyway so I
know what I would do in this situation
Alex Goldman do you want to hear my bad
strategy for dealing with this go for it
so I like I do not suggest that you do
this I would write this person an email
and I would be like here's why the lip
relationship has deteriorated between
you and I and I will outline to you in
this short bulleted list the mistakes
that you made and and it will be very
awkward and I would only do it because
in my in my like deep-seated heart I
would believe that I was helping them
but I probably wouldn't actually be yeah
that's bad advice Hank I'm sorry well
I'm glad I'm glad that we're on the same
page that like the thing that I would do
is not the right thing to do I I can
tell you what I would probably do which
is I would probably goes to the person
which is also bad advice I mean is it
people get ghosted and for a little for
less bad things than being a jerk to
your family repeatedly right but I guess
but I guess the thing in this this email
that makes me feel like ghosting might
be okay is that Paula describes this
person as a as a full college friend not
like a Christ friend a best friend the
closest she comes as I used to like
spending time about just I used to like
spending time with him mm-hmm right it
does not appear that you uh it just not
appear that like it kind of feels a
little bit like maybe we could take our
friendship to the next level and then
you found out that you couldn't and that
wasn't going to happen like MIT like not
like the next level like we're gonna
hook up but like we're gonna go from
like acquaintances to good friends by
having this like together time at thanks
give
and that didn't work out and so now
you're just acquaintances forever I will
say though that bringing someone home
with you for Thanksgiving presupposes a
certain amount of closeness doesn't it I
mean yes and no I actually was in a very
similar situation to this one time where
I ended up going to my friends like like
lake house because I didn't like I was
gonna be left at school alone and so
they like took me to the lake house and
like we went like I'd like hole held
onto his his like hips while he jet
skied you know and that's like like
physical closeness and then and then it
was like like we didn't like we did not
resonate on a friend level and I'd we
never hung out after that right like we
were like like it just like I ended up
getting dragged along and like spending
all this time and being like well that
didn't work out and like you're into
stuff that I'm not into was more what it
was like he was like driving 95 miles an
hour on the interstate and I was like so
this is like what a jet ski anymore so
this is like when you go on a date when
you go on a couple dates and then you're
like let's take a weekend away and when
you actually spend a weekend with the
person you're like this is this is awful
yeah yeah and I think I think it's okay
I like I do I do like it like deep down
I want to know what was the root of this
that maybe this person like like was
feeling really uncomfortable or judged
or was having a real bad day just
because they like had to spend
Thanksgiving with strangers but but like
also if you don't want to hang out with
them you don't have to be friends with
people I don't wanna be friends with
right at the same time if this person
does want to salvage their relationship
I think that they need to say something
yeah you could do that you could be like
what was up with that that's the but
that's exactly what I was gonna say the
way you do it is you say did you notice
like maybe that you were being a little
rude to my family and then if they're
like what are you talking about be like
well here are six examples of the when
you threw a turkey leg at my grandmother
yeah maybe you could like why would that
have happened and sometimes people will
just say like I don't know I was just
really uncomfortable and like I liked
them but like I didn't know how to talk
to them bla bla bla and like you can
come to some kind of understanding
mm-hmm so and and do go into it with
some some not harsh but specific
examples because I often will enter into
a conversation where I'm like you need
to stop acting this way people are like
what do you mean and I'm like I don't
know you just do a thing like I should
have had my recorder out and recorded
you when you've said that mean thing I
don't know I can't remember now right
but yeah if somebody got hit with a
turkey leg you got bring that up yeah so
our advice I guess is ghost them if you
don't care um confront them if you do
all right our next question Austin asks
dear Hank and Alex I live in Minnesota
where we tend to have long dark winters
I live in Montana it's the same here
while snow is wonderful and I actually
really do like winter all that darkness
can be hard on your mental health one of
the things I've always found makes me
feel better is a crackling fire in a
fireplace or a lit candle or two there's
something so cheery about having a
little flame flickering inside when it's
dark out lots of folks in Minnesota are
descended from Scandinavian immigrants
and I found a couple of years ago that
there's this word in Norwegian and
Danish to describe this cozy inside with
fire fielding Piggott or whatever
however that's pronounced so here's my
question is there a scientific recycle
logical reason that candles and fires in
a fireplace raise our morale like the
author not the city
Austin was like last year the year of
hugga because I heard about this a lot
last year and I feel like I'm still here
Mike like my wife just came home with
two different like hygge specific book
like cookbooks this is literally the
first time I've ever seen this word so
it wasn't last year was not the year of
whatever the hell that word is where do
you live you live in New York City I
mean I live in New Jersey I work in New
York City okay okay
yeah
but I just feel like like like coziness
is probably not a huge part of the
culture of New York where you know it
gets cold and dreary but also like
people are like I don't know like I just
don't like picture people and in like
the big city like cuddling up and just
spending time with our hot chocolate and
their cat you guys got stuff to do yeah
that's not a big New York City thing I
did grow up in Michigan yeah as we did
everything I've there so yeah I've been
working on a video for awhile that so I
grew up in Florida and then I moved to
Montana this was a pretty big climate
difference there and and so like I've
adjusted very well to like living in a
cold place but I just my assistant moved
from Florida to Montana and she's like I
do not understand how you do this and so
I want to like basically for her but
also everyone like how do you live in a
cold place and at pieces of advice and
one of them is like this like I think
the word cozy is pretty good at
describing this where you have blankets
around and you light a candle if you
don't have a fireplace and like you have
it's dark and you sort of like lean in
what I've what i've heard about Higa is
that it's sort of I'm sure that I'm
pronouncing this so well it's it's it's
sort of that except with friends so
there's sort of a social element to it
where it's like everybody gets together
and we're all gonna like put on blankets
and like chat and have hot drinks and
that's like like that's a lovely thing
like I do like that I like and and I
like I don't know if they're like I'm
not gonna say that there's a
psychological or scientific thing here
but what I will say is there are
definitely when you end up in a
situation there are ways to to frame it
positively and ways to frame it
negatively and I think that if you
surround yourselves with with ways to
frame a situation positively even if
it's not super positive like the Sun
went down and it's 3:30 in the afternoon
that you can find ways to sort of like
neat like form that into something
that's nice and and that is just based
on culture and it's based on you and
it's based on your brain chemistry it's
based on
things and like but just trying to
figure out those the puzzle pieces to
fit together to make something nice when
it wouldn't necessarily be automatically
nice I think it's like I'm making the
thumbs-up gesture right now and I think
the coziness and maybe coziness with
friends are really good ways to do that
I that the only reasons for winter are
sledding and coziness like sledding and
a lot of blankets you know how you know
how like when was the last time you went
sledding Alex Goldman uh well I have a
two-year-old so I dragged him around in
a sled last year my hope is that okay
this year he'll be fine I don't I didn't
I didn't say when was the last time you
took someone you put your butt on a sled
and went down a hill because I did this
when I was 30 when I was 35 years old
and I discovered that my body is
different now I did not feel good the
next day like hard to get off of the bed
it was actually a couple years ago it
wasn't that long ago yeah Oh like yeah I
I feel I did not realize that sledding
was a physical activity until I uh until
I did it as a middle-aged man I mean a
huge part of it is slamming yourself
into the snow as you launch yourself
down oh yeah just bam bam bam bam just
right I mean we have pretty intense
sledding hills as you might imagine and
yeah it was yeah I
my back hurts just thinking about it but
very fun I agree sledding is is a high
quality activity but you know there's
like weighted blankets that are supposed
to you know improve like improve your
emotional state there's like sort of
these yeah I I mean that's just what
being coziest you just toss a bunch of
blankets on yourself and then you feel
nice and like you're wearing a giant LED
baby bib it's great like I mean I like I
remember going and getting x-rays and
loving the feeling of them putting those
LED things on you so like that is that's
a
good thing too that you brought up but I
do like I love it when somebody puts a
big like leaded baby apron on me I have
to give credit to there is a Twitter
user named Leon his Twitter handles le y
ou N and he has a tweet in which he is
chanting heavy baby bib and then the
dentist comes in the lead apron and the
image is so funny I imagine someone in a
dentist's baby bib heavy baby so much
respect Ileana that's good it's good I
think we answered that one right yeah
yeah guys I was gonna get my only other
my only other hypothesis is that maybe
we're like moths and we just like to run
around in circles near near Knights in
flames
chanting heavy baby bib alright here we
go dear Alex and Hank I just started
college and I've made some new friends
but now I have a problem am I supposed
to get them Christmas presents I mean
I've only known them a few months so how
long are you supposed to be friends with
someone before you start buying each
other Christmas presents how do you know
who you're supposed to buy presents for
I really need some dubious advice
presents and problems Laura I have very
strong oh do you yeah I cuz I have I
have I have a suggestion but I do not
have strong feelings so hit me with your
strong feelings and then I'll hit you
with my suggestion when I was in college
at my at my best I was making minimum
wage like I had no money
mm-hmm I had a meal plan so I wasn't
hunting for food pop-tarts but but you
shouldn't buy anybody Christmas presents
when you're in college if anything you
should like make them Christmas presents
I mean mm-hmm
I'm old enough that when I was me when I
was in college it was like mix CDs and
things like that but right right but no
one's gonna get mad
No if you don't get them a Christmas
present no ah here's my suggestion if if
you feel like maybe there would be like
on a like a level of appreciation that
would be inferred by other people like
oh this person is valuing me if you gave
them the present then give them the one
of the following items candy something
from the dollar store
that's it and like and like a card
that's made out of printer paper where
you folded it in half and you said a
Merry Christmas here's some candy
because I think that there's like I
think receiving a gift is like is a
separate thing from the gift itself and
and so like it doesn't matter if you
spent 25 cents on this gift the fact
that you are just doing it is okay it's
like a plus like no here's yes piece of
printer paper Merry Christmas
open it up on the inside scotch-taped is
a biz it is a quarter boom perfect
Christmas presents for your contacts
really good a quarter is really good
that feels like something that your
parents would do so it feels like if
you're homesick that feels really nice
yeah yeah when I first started dating my
wife I didn't I was a terrible gift
giver I was just like oh well did she
reform you are you better now she did
she you know she was like listen you
like to get me things that are like
expensive and electronic and blah blah
blah and she's like I don't really want
those there's nothing to them they're
just they're like tchotchkes that are
great and I'm sure very useful but like
if you're getting me a gift I want you
to get me a gift because it's something
that you think I will really love so now
it's like you know like she would value
she had she had a much better reaction
to getting like a plank that she could
put a book on in the bathtub than she
did to like an iPod yeah and that is it
yeah a valuable lesson I think I thought
about you and not only did I get you
this thing but I also installed it
or had it installed as the case may be
yeah I actually got for Christmas
Catherine's gonna get a thing that I
will have installed and she won't even
know that she got this Christmas present
until she opens the right door and she'd
be like oh that's convenient that's nice
that's better than the way it was before
and that's what that's what you know
your your 20th year of being together is
like I noticed that you were annoyed by
something and I fixed it you're less
annoyed now right I was paying attention
to you and that's what we all want it's
just to be valued anyway you are under
no obligation to get your friends
Christmas presents no god no
meet like a like a coloring book and
some crayons like like if you spend more
than five dollars on anybody's present
you are actually making the situation
worse yeah you're making it any they're
gonna feel like they need to buy stuff
and it gets ya and yeah you know what
will be the best Christmas present this
is something that I would want if I were
in college if you somehow have access to
a part of the campus that I am not
supposed to be on take me to that part
that is a take me to the bell tower if
you have it if you have access to a lab
full of spiders take me to that today
sure yeah yeah show me show me the weird
Natural History Museum that that's a
working museum and not a public one yes
this next question comes from Don who
asks dear Hank and Alex my question is
simple does any light from other stars
reach earth and remain visible to our
eyes on the ground so of course the
light is visible to our eyes because we
look at them and we see them but does it
hit the ground is my shadow less dark
because of the light from other suns
filling in the darkness can I get like a
slight three-point lighting setup or
like one hundred thousand million point
lighting if in this case if I simply
stand in the correct spot on earth at
the right time of day / night I'm not a
duck Don what do you think what do you
think Alex about stars you know about
this man this is I'm making a confession
this is a dear Alex and Hank exclusive I
am so bad at mathematics and astronomy
that the only way I made it out of my
astronomy class was cheating on one test
oh man yeah it's been 20 years I think I
think it's okay I think the statute of
limitations has run out I don't think
they're going to revoke my diploma but
I'm very very bad at science all right
well so Don the answer to the question
is simply that yes there is starlight
and and if on a moonless night if you
are in the middle of nowhere and there
is no source of light there is still
light because of stars and there will
still and you it will still be like each
individual star is casting its
individual shadow but there will be no
shadows because there's a dome of them
and so they're casting in every
direction which is really cool and and
you can you can detect that light and
there is actually a weird thing where if
the universe was infinitely large and
infinitely old there would be so much
starlight that would have reached us
that the sky would actually just be the
color of the Sun and the brightness of
the Sun the only reason it's it's dark
and black is because even though we
think that the universe is likely just
sort of an infinite miss of stars that
light hasn't had time to get to us yet
hmm
so at some point if the universe is
infinite the the there will be no night
time and no daytime just sort of this
blinding what white brightness well to
be clear the universe will never be
infinitely old so that is a that is a
supposition of a thing that cannot occur
but yeah if if it was or if the speed of
light were instantaneous and all of the
light from an infinite field of stars
all had already reached us there is a
minute physics
about this called why is the sky dark at
night which will explain all of that and
it's very good and it has video parts
and is only three minutes long even
though it's minutephysics
it's three minute physics so yeah weird
starlight is a thing and in fact they
are people who have even tried to create
solar panels that are sensitive enough
that they can generate electricity from
starlight which they can do but it is
more it is more like useful for
detecting very faint amounts of light
than it is for actually producing
electricity it's just sort of a way to
say like this is a very sensitive solar
panel oh okay
well this is more than I that I've I've
learned more about astronomy in these
last two minutes in many years so thank
you okay alright dear Alex and Hank I am
an American I recently moved to Germany
in an attempt to find my bearings in my
new city almost everything reminds me of
people I knew in the u.s. sometimes I'm
reminded of old friends or ex-boyfriends
I've lost touch with is it ever okay to
reach out to someone just to say hi is
it weird to let someone know you were
thinking of them or is it nice I don't
want I don't know what I want out of the
interaction I think I just want to
connect to people would everyone be
better off if I focused on making new
friends for better or worst as in like
bratwurst bratwurst Tessa
okay
yeah no it's normal to reach out to old
friends I don't know about ex-boyfriends
because like I don't know if they're
gonna be like so what does this mean
what does this mean this is what like
there might be some amount of I don't
know what how you left it with them but
yeah I'd like it when my old friends
reach out to me and they're like hey how
are you doing now I'm good I live in
Germany I eat lots of German food and
hang out with German people
that's weird I thought that is it do you
is that does anybody think that's
I feel like this question says old
friends but it's more geared toward the
ex-boyfriends thing like I think that
like yeah because because it's
definitely not weird with old friends
yeah but it might be a little weird with
ex-boyfriends yeah I think that is a
good piece of intuition Alex I think
that it is only weird okay this is gonna
sound this is gonna this is a tautology
but I'm gonna say it anyway it's weird
if it's weird like if you have a had a
bad partying relationship with that
person then yes it's super weird or
right like if you broke up with them and
they were like I would like to keep this
going and you were like no and then you
reach out and you're like hey I live in
Germany now how you do and they're gonna
be like okay well I got a chance with
Tessa now so let's let's put up my
entire life on hold I'm gonna move to
Germany but I don't I mean I'm friends
with exes it's okay to be friends with
exes and yeah sometimes it's nice to
feel like you have an anchor when you
are totally unmoored and sort of lost in
another country it feels it's tough to
move to another city to say nothing of
another country so if it's not weird I
say do it at the same time you would be
better off if you focused on making new
friends Tessa yeah and yet I have no
advice for how to make new friends as an
American in Germany I because I have not
done that I think that I don't have
enough information to totally say but if
you speak German I would say if there's
you have a hobby or something and
there's like a meet-up for it you should
go do that
I loved radio when I was in college in
my first semester of college I was like
lonely and desperate and I was like
maybe I should drop out and move home
and I cried every day and one time
someone asked me how I was doing at the
food co-op and I started to cry because
I was doing so badly like it was just I
was miserable the whole time and I
almost didn't come back and
the semester I returned I just got
involved at the radio station we didn't
have a radio show I was just a volunteer
there which meant I would do stuff like
cataloging records and things like that
and I met everyone I knew a college
through the radio station mm-hmm it's
just go find something that you like to
do and go do it that doesn't mean that
you shouldn't talk to your friends back
home I'm sure that even people who
haven't heard from you in a long time
care about you and want to hear from you
but I know what it's like to be in a
situation that feels isolating and alone
and I'm sorry Tessa that you're there
and I hope that you're doing okay thanks
Alex
this next question comes from Tori who
asks dear Hank and Alex why are all of
my pencils number two what does this
mean are all of my number one and three
pencils languishing in some drawer lost
and alone shouldn't all my pencils be
number one are they not worthy of praise
and adoration who in the world uses
number one and number three pencils why
are they not allowed to be used on
standardized tests how far does this
number system go are there number 10
pencils is this a Ticonderoga conspiracy
I hope I'm not the only one confused
looking for my number one pencil Tori of
the land of Ticonderoga do they have
Ticonderoga pencils another country are
people gonna be really confused by that
I I don't know I know
in any case Ticonderoga is a pencil
company in America there's also a place
I assume that Ticonderoga pencils are
made in Ticonderoga which is a wonderful
word now that I've said it a bunch of
towns yeah towns times Ticonderoga is a
nice nice word there's a there's a
there's a place in Los Angeles called
Cahuenga Pass that's also I'm saying
over and over again say yeah I did some
research on number number three pencils
but before I get there yeah that is
confusing because they're they don't
show up in normal life but there is a
difference there is a thing here that is
being indicated by the
numbers on your pencils and it is the
hardness of their lead or their graphite
we why do I need to know how hard the
lead is does that affect how it looks it
does so the harder the pencil lead the
softer the line so a number one pencil
has the softest of the LEDs before it
just starts to be crumbly and that
graphite will make a darker line and the
pencil will wear more quickly and number
one pencils are used by by like
professionals who are really aidan to
their pencils having really dark marks
number two pencils where less quickly
but they still have relatively dark
marks whereas number three and four and
I don't know how high it goes but those
pencils are so hard that they might not
be dark enough to make the scantron
sheets read the pencil so the reason
that we use number-two pencils is
because they show up on scantrons unless
yeah they're a good mix good mix between
yeah those two things I'm looking I just
googled number eight pencils and it
looks like they exist really I'd like to
try on number eight pencil that sounds
like it would be a very very hard read
faber castell pencil since 1761 the
graphite pencil castel nine thousand
eight be a genuinely classic pencil was
launched by count Alexander von
faber-castell in 1905 its quality and
finally graduated degrees of hardness
have made it a firm favorite with
artists and illustrators it's led fully
bonded with wood surrounding with the
wood surrounded is therefore
particularly break resistant and it's
available in 16 different degrees of
hardness
[Applause]
it goes from this it now gets confusing
to me because there are there are
letters after it so there's there's like
a for me who knows what those letters
sorry yeah oh my gosh I mean people get
really into their writing implements I
have had conversations with people that
I did not want to be in that went on for
a very long time about pens and I was
just like man my relationship with pens
is they I take them from hotels that's
my path yes me too me too
I'm like an incessant doodler but I'm
not a good artist so I don't have like a
predilection toward fancy pens right
yeah that's the thing that's the thing
to notice that a lot of pencils like you
know you could all you like an art
supply store and there's pencils and
every thought you could have about what
a pencil might be capable of they have
more thoughts because pencils when
they're being used for art are theirs
there are a number of different things
that can be done there all right is why
this podcast is brought to you by all of
the pencils it's got this you got a
number 4b you want that yes you want a
number you want a number 10 a yeah we
got that too
every pencil available probably at your
art store but definitely in Ticonderoga
where apparently pencils come from this
podcast is also brought to you by
starlight ah it's not just from the Sun
anymore and if the universe gets
sufficiently old it'll be everywhere
it'll be everywhere and probably all are
thought all the life on Earth will just
be fried podcast is also brought to you
by jet skiing with a not very close
acquaintance word this episode is also
brought to you by the heavy baby bib
it's so comfortable
just lay down we'll place it over you
and then you know you might get your
teeth drilled you might you know sit in
front of a crackling fire who can say
all right Lee this podcast is also
brought to you actually by story blocks
story blocks is a service that is on the
Internet and it gets you access to a
large gigantic library of video audio
and picture stuff right now they have a
triple bundle going on where for a year
you could pay a hundred and forty nine
dollars and get all three of those
things where usually they are 149
dollars a year each story blocks is
extremely useful tool for people who
make content and it used to be very very
difficult to get this to get footage or
audio clips or pictures to use in your
content that you would then be using
properly and not stealing from an artist
and those artists would be compensated
for the work that they were doing and
now story box does that it connects
people who want to make stuff with
people who have already made it so that
you can make your stuff better with the
stuff that people have made and those
people will get paid for it and it's
good story box has two different ways
that you can get content there's the
membership content which will be
available to anybody who pays and then
there's a stuff that is available that
you will have to pay extra for and those
are the the marketplace things and that
money goes directly to the person who
created it and story box is a useful
thing and and those ala carte
marketplace things range in value from
like four bucks to like 50 bucks we at
our production company you story box in
order to make our content better and do
it inexpensively and we very much
appreciate them supporting this podcast
and and also supporting this sort of the
creative community on the internet
making us better at not stealing and
also and also getting getting more good
stuff made in the world Thank You story
blocks if you want to check out story
books you can go to story blocks comm
slash dear Hank and John that will help
us out and they're there you can find
the triple bundle where you'll get all
of their things that usually cost one
hundred and fifty each but for just
hundred fifty for all three of them so
thank you to story box alright let's do
one more question before we get to the
news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I
assume that you brought some news from
AFC Wimbledon
oh yeah you know it okay good all right
hit me hit me with that last question
this says this is from page it says
hello brothers I'm gonna assume she knew
that I was going to be on the show and
just thinks of us as having a fraternal
relationship mm-hmm
hello brothers I have a short-range
radio device that you can plug into your
phone it supposed to be used as an
alternate if your car doesn't have an
exact scored I've been using it to prank
my friends for a few weeks now this is
good i I've had it play some bits of
your podcast and more recently I made it
play cryptic messages my friends are
super spooked and still totally
oblivious any ideas for next steps in
the prank do I play more cryptic
messages other things any advice is
greatly appreciated oh my god oh and
sign off for turn the page we do name
specific sign ups here at dear Hank and
John if you hadn't caught on Alex this
is great this is very good I think that
like I am often iffy on pranks because I
think that they could be and to like be
careful that you're not freaking your
friends out too much but I like this I
have a similar I had a long-running
similar prank where I would sew up my
laptop I named it like tells it like
it's a skew to like put the name your
name in when you have your laptop and I
put just a like a random name in that
was not mine just because I did not like
I didn't care and and and then I found
that that meant that when I air-dropped
people it came from a name that was not
my name and then I found that a lot of
people in my office had their airdrop
open so I would just send them weird
things and they would accept them and
then I would and then and they would be
like who and so finally I let every like
it came out that it was me who had been
doing it and I was like what did you
think and they were like I thought
honestly that there was a guy who would
like drive by our office and airdrop us
files
and I was like yeah I guess like airdrop
you like et in a coat yeah that was just
a guy like just back in the yeah back in
the early days of the of Wi-Fi there
used to be people who would drive around
neighborhoods and try and hack into
other people's Wi-Fi networks yeah they
called it what they called it war
driving because it was it was similar to
the way that Matthew Broderick's
character and wargames would just dial
every number until he got until he
connected to someone and what they were
imagining is like someone who is just
sort of war driving your office I
imagine someone parked in your parking
lot in the corner just being like ah I
can't wait to send them a weird image
I'm totally gonna get him today
yeah so maybe this is amazing and you
can rename your computer and like have a
thing that's playing and then have the
image show up that's related to it later
that day and you airdrop them a file
that is related to the weird podcast
that you're playing or the weird pasca
podcast you're creating from ghosts
weird ghost podcast like that see I
always feel like if you have the
opportunity to do this you should it
shouldn't just be sort of like random
bits and pieces of weirdness like I feel
like you should come up with a narrative
that is plausibly disembodied voices
this this like disembodied voice is
coming out of this short-range radio and
then play those like play come up with
some kind of story
right well like the thing I don't want
to do is have it just be like weird
ghosts so you want like I think that it
should be there should be more to it
like there should be a person who's
stuck in the radio station or or who's
become a radio there like a person who'd
like got like like a transporter
accident in the Star Trek and instead
like there would they got shocked at the
radio station like something funny and
cute
just like like no screaming or or you
know like like this is how I died stuff
yeah this is just how I converted into a
radio broadcast this reminds me of in
gremlins - and one of the gremlins has
turned into electricity yeah forget
about that I don't know like that do
that except maybe it is a gremlin maybe
maybe it's you just start making weird
gremlin noises I yeah I I mean I kind of
want to leave this in your hands don't
be too mean but definitely keep it going
page I have I think that just by virtue
of the fact that you came up with this
prank in the first place first place I
have total faith that you are going to
come up with a great great prank to play
on them right so I don't like about my
only contribution is maybe if you can
work in airdrop so that it's happening
in multiple media simultaneously they
can be like okay this is real weird now
this is real weird it's happening
there's if you can figure out how to
project something onto the TV then you
get the trifecta oh yeah and it's all
happening good luck you can have in the
night have a scavenger hunt and at the
end of the scavenger hunt they get up
they get a piece of printer paper folded
in half and it says Merry Christmas ISM
there's a quarter inside there's a
quarter taped to the inside yeah it was
all worth it you got that quarter all
right Alex news from AFC Wimbledon AFC
Wimbledon shot down by the wizardry of
odds I don't know doesn't sound good
former former Dulwich Hamlet playmaker
Nets twice so far so good
there is a former Dulwich Hamlet
midfielder named heir who knows tumour
who I assume they call Oz and he's
capable of performing
surgery and he he proved that it is
skill not size that wins matches its AFC
Wimbledon paid the price for early
mischances so what I've learned about
him so far is that he is skillful but
small used to hang out with dolet he
used to hang out with something called
Dulwich Hamlet and people call him as he
scored a scorching free-kick and a very
rare error by keeper George long on
Saturday gifted him the ball 30 yards
out
so it was 2o against AFC Wimbledon I'm
sorry to say because of how great let me
get his name again because of how great
err who knows tumor is I hope I'm
pronouncing his name right seems
unlikely but that is life that is that
is the life of AFC Wimbledon news as far
as I can tell especially British towns
who knows who knows but it sounds like I
have Co ableton lost a game the AFC
Wimbledon lost a game to someone who
used to be part of the Dulwich Hamlet
yes I do love I do love the names of
towns there's something weird about it
like it makes like like it resonates
with like my ancestral memory because I
am very like I did 23andme and I'm very
British Irish which is not surprising
considering all the people who I know
are my family and yeah there's like I
like look at the names of the subway
stations and I'm like this is different
cuz all these words are based on my
language whereas in America words are
based on like every language
we got like lots of Spanish words and
lots of Native American words and lots
of you know there's some like we got you
know York we got New York happenin up
there but like you know I grew up in
Florida where most of most of yeah it's
just yeah and out here in Montana like
Montana as a Spanish word but there's
something interesting where it's like
that is working with some part of my
linguistic brain
in a cool way interesting yeah I don't
have this feeling at all that I you just
like you dislike your words it's always
it just feels like it's like a bunch of
old English words that are starting
together if they're like done which shop
fir'd sure main on Gordon string didn't
yeah also what I'm noticing here is that
uh they're mushy Wimbledon I don't know
if they some of the seats in the some of
the seats apparently in there this might
be old news for your listeners some of
the seats in the their arena are named
for a company called chem flow so you
can buy Terrace tickets for the Rye
guests Ragus stand or the chem flow end
it seems as though you can buy tickets
for a certain part of it called case
yeah well that's I think that they that
different companies sponsor different
areas of the stadium and so then you
know which area you're buying the ticket
in and like I never want to sit in a
place called K it does not sound like
the place that I would by the end I
would choose if I have the opportunity
it's cheap though so the the the the
news for people who care about this I
just looked up the league one table and
AFC Wimbledon is in 20th of 24 which
means that they are one spot out of
being last or out of being in the
relegation zone I think is what what
it's called so they are not that it is
there it's hanging on by the skin of
their teeth and they need to win some
some football games as as good as I can
do in terms of how to analyze what they
well they need to learn that it's skill
not size and right as the wizardry of Oz
taught them that was yes whoever that
person is the news from Mars so as so
two pieces two pieces of things one you
may have heard about this weird asteroid
that we think was we like may be really
skinny and long but that seems very
unlikely so
just had a weird coloration and we could
only see the skinny long part of it and
the rest of it was very dark but it was
very weird and it was an object from
outside of our solar system and it came
flying through our solar system the
first one we've ever detected an object
from outside of our solar system it is
it is of course a thing that happens but
we're getting better at detecting
objects like that now because we are
kind of on the lookout for meteorites
that might hit earth good doing better
job of that which is great good job how
are we able to how are we able to know
that it's from another solar system so
its trajectory is hyperbolic so almost
like all the stuff in our solar system
its trajectory is it comes like you can
see the orbit and the orbit might not be
a circle in fact very often they're
these huge long looping things where it
comes into the inner solar system and
then goes way out but then eventually
it's gonna come back and this object
came in at a speed and a trajectory so
it came in not in the plane of the solar
system
so our solar system is like a plate I
mean it came in from from up instead of
from side to side and then it and then
it came in went extremely fast looped
around the Sun and then would right back
out so it had way too much kinetic
energy for it to have been from from
here it was not like sometimes this will
happen when like two objects interact
and one grabs a bunch of its kinetic
energy through a gravity interaction and
then it will get enough energy to
slingshot out of the solar system but
this is way too fast for that so it's
definitely from elsewhere and they so we
won't ever know anything more about this
object because it was going too fast and
we took readings at its closest point
and now it's way farther away and we'll
continue getting farther away but the
question is could we have like if we had
some time in the future would there have
been a possibility to actually chase
something like this down and be like
well we don't we're not gonna get a
chance to observe another solar system
any time soon because they're you know
light-years away
could we read
- this thing and and I know this doesn't
sound like Mars news yet but could we
get to get to this thing and and study
another solar system by studying an
object that made its way to us from an
hour another solar system and the answer
to that question is with SpaceX's
current plan for its big old Mars rocket
called the bfr we could actually get
something going fast enough to catch up
to not this object because that thing
isn't built yet but to another object -
like it that HAP that like happened by
so if we were ready and the bfr was a
thing that existed and it was like
driving people from like LA to Sydney
every afternoon like Elon Musk seems to
think as possible we could load one of
these things up and get it going fast
enough that would it would actually be
capable of catching up with like if it
existed today it we could have launched
it and it would have caught up with this
object which I'm not gonna try to
pronounce its name because it's in
Hawaiian and I would be bad at it so so
yeah that that is an exciting potential
side effect of building a rocket capable
of going to Mars is also you would have
a rocket capable of chasing down an
object that was flung into our solar
system from another solar system being
able to do research on that object and
learning about what life or not what
life but what what the universe is like
very far away and in a very different
place so that's just a maybe but also a
cool so I'm glad god yeah that is you
know that God to know that somebody was
thinking about that and and ran the
numbers Alex what are we learned today
we learned that the greatest gift a
person can get is a piece of printer
printer paper folded in half with a
quarter tape to it and we learned that
if somebody whacked your grandma with a
turkey leg at Thanksgiving that like you
can toast them you could take it you
could just be like no thanks it's that's
that and we learned that the number two
pencil has just meant one in a long
lineage of how so many with various
numbers and apparently letters H and B
oh who knows what that's about at least
and finally we learned that
the opposite of anarchy is learning what
anarchy actually is you may be oh good
I'm so glad Alex thank you so much for
joining me I am a big fan of reply also
it's just an absolute treat to hang out
and talk and thanks for joining me on
the patreon livestream before this all
the patreon patrons got or the ones who
were able to show up got a special treat
of Alex Goldman of hanging out and
talking about net neutrality and
marshmallows um so if you want to
support us you can do that at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
also if you want to support us just tell
your friends what a great podcast this
is and also tell them about reply-all
because it is very good and let's be
honest better than this different we
actually much more work we in honor of
being on the show I actually created a
special page called there's actually
three URLs you can go to
it's called Raphael dot pizza slash dear
Hank reply all that Pizza slash Dear
John and Raphael dot pizza slash dear
Alex they all go to the same place
though it's just a page of some of our
favorite episodes if you want to get
started with oh that's our knife so
that's wonderful so go ahead and check
those out it's I think eight or nine
episodes that we really like and
listeners really liked so yeah go ahead
and check those out and thanks so much
for having me on the show I really
appreciate it
this podcast is produced by rosianna
halse rojas and sheridan Gibson it's
edited by nicholas jenkins our head of
community and communications victoria
bon giorno the theme music you're
hearing now and at the beginning is by
the great gunnarolla and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]